Introducing the all-new Kia Nero EV. They say the first step is always the hardest, to walk into the unknown. But it's when we have the courage to step forward that the real adventure begins. With up to 407 kilometres of range on a single charge, the Kia Nero EV is a subcompact SUV that lets you travel farther and smarter. The all-new Kia Nero EV, your first step into the electric world. Kia, movement that inspires. The eastern side of the city of Albuquerque, New Mexico, is closed in by mountains.
隆重推出全新的起亚Nero EV。人们常说，第一步总是最艰难的，因为要迈向未知。但正是当我们有勇气向前迈进时，真正的冒险才刚刚开始。起亚Nero EV是一款紧凑型SUV，单次充电续航里程可达407公里，让您走得更远、更智能。全新的起亚Nero EV，您迈向电动世界的第一步。起亚，激发灵感的移动体验。新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基市的东侧被群山环绕。
On the city's west side, a mesa rises out of the Rio Grande Valley. In 2005, subdivisions and new housing were being built along the west mesa. The construction pressed up against the vast desert that stretches beyond where you will find tumbleweeds, high-tension wires and trash. It is a desolate, isolated spot. In 2008, the economy crashed and the new homes stopped being built. It was on a 92-acre lot of land on the west mesa one year later, 2009, where subdivision work had started but construction had never gone ahead,
在城市的西侧，一座平顶山从格兰德河谷拔地而起。2005年，西平顶山沿线正在兴建住宅区和新房。建筑工程一直推进到广阔的沙漠边缘，那里随处可见风滚草、高压电线和垃圾。这是一个荒凉、孤立的地方。2008年，经济崩溃，新房建设停止。一年后的2009年，在西平顶山一块92英亩的土地上，尽管细分地块的工作已经开始，但建筑工程从未推进，
where a serial killer's burial ground was found. Detective Ida Lopez from the Albuquerque Police Department was assigned to the missing persons unit in 2005. She was the only detective assigned there. It was low priority work. Detective Lopez was the first officer to sense something wasn't right in Albuquerque. Two missing persons reports came across her desk. Both women fit a similar profile. They were known sex workers who also used drugs and they vanished without a trace,
在那里发现了一处连环杀手的埋尸地。阿尔伯克基警察局的艾达·洛佩兹警探于2005年被分配到失踪人口部门。她是那里唯一的警探。这是一项优先级较低的工作。洛佩兹警探是第一位感觉到阿尔伯克基有些不对劲的警官。两份失踪人口报告摆在她的桌上。两名女性的情况非常相似。她们都是已知的性工作者，同时也吸毒，并且消失得无影无踪，
not letting friends or family know of their whereabouts. It's common in these types of cases for family members to hear. Well, that's just part of the lifestyle they live. Sometimes people don't want to be found. They don't have to keep contact with you or tell you where they are. It doesn't mean they're missing. And that's exactly what many families of the victims in this case heard. But Detective Lopez couldn't ignore the similarities in these two missing girls' appearance
没有让朋友或家人知道她们的下落。在这些类型的案件中，家属听到这样的话很常见：“嗯，这只是她们生活方式的一部分。有时人们不想被找到。她们不必与你保持联系或告诉你她们在哪里。这并不意味着她们失踪了。”而这正是此案中许多受害者家属所听到的。但洛佩兹警探无法忽视这两名失踪女孩在外貌上的相似之处，
or the circumstances in which they vanished. She started looking into other cases involving women who had disappeared from Albuquerque that matched the same profile. She discovered more and more cases that all bore eerie similarities. The list of missing women eventually grew to 24. Some were crossed off that list as time went on, eventually, turning up either back in the Albuquerque or in other parts of the country. But it was clear something wasn't right.
以及她们消失时的环境。她开始调查其他涉及从阿尔伯克基失踪且符合相同特征的女性案件。她发现了越来越多具有诡异相似之处的案例。失踪女性名单最终增加到了24人。随着时间的推移，有些人从名单上被划掉，最终要么回到了阿尔伯克基，要么出现在了全国的其他地方。但很明显，有些事情不对劲。
The common thing the missing girls shared was that they were involved in sex work and many battled drug addiction. The area of the Albuquerque all of the victims were known to work is referred to by some as the war zone. In recent years, the area was rebranded as the International District. There is an area there on Central Avenue that is something of a red light district. It's a place where the most vulnerable, the most desperate show up
这些失踪女孩的共同点是她们都从事性工作，且许多人与毒瘾作斗争。阿尔伯克基所有受害者已知的工作区域被一些人称为“战区”。近年来，该地区被重新命名为“国际区”。那里中央大道上有一个区域，算是红灯区。这是一个最脆弱、最绝望的人出现的地方，
looking for money, looking for drugs. It's also where people prey on those who have no place else to turn. Detective Lopez hit the streets to try and find out as much information as she could, questioning anyone who would speak to her about the missing girls, trying to find out about their last movements if they knew each other, trying to find that common thread. It wasn't long before Detective Lopez started to hear about the rumours circulating the streets at the time. There were whispers around town that Albuquerque had its own version of Jack the Ripper,
寻找金钱，寻找毒品。这也是人们捕食那些走投无路之人的地方。洛佩兹警探走上街头，试图尽可能多地获取信息，询问任何愿意与她交谈的人关于失踪女孩的情况，试图找出她们最后的行踪，看她们是否认识彼此，试图找到那个共同点。没过多久，洛佩兹警探就开始听到当时在街头流传的谣言。城里有传言说，阿尔伯克基有自己的“开膛手杰克”，
a psycho praying on vulnerable victims who he felt society wasn't going to miss. The rumours even mentioned specifically the missing girls were dead and were buried on the West Mesa. As that information was just rumour at the time, there was no evidence to go on, no specific spot to start. The West Mesa was too vast of an area to start searching for victims who might be buried there. It's the desert. Where would the police even begin? They needed something more. And so Detective Lopez kept working, kept pounding the pavement,
一个捕食脆弱受害者的精神病患者，他认为社会不会想念她们。谣言甚至具体提到失踪的女孩已经死了，并被埋在西平顶山。由于这些信息在当时只是谣言，没有证据支持，也没有具体的地点可以开始调查。西平顶山面积太大，无法开始寻找可能埋在那里的受害者。那是沙漠。警方甚至从哪里开始？他们需要更多的线索。于是洛佩兹警探继续工作，继续奔走，
asking questions, trying to find out what happened. Part of the investigation process carried out by Detective Lopez was asking for dental records and taking DNA samples from family members of the missing girls. This work would prove vital later on. As the years passed though, nothing much came of the investigation. There was very little media coverage of the missing girls. Not many people seemed to care. It was never really in the public's minds.
询问问题，试图找出发生了什么。洛佩兹警探进行的调查过程的一部分是要求提供牙科记录，并从失踪女孩的家属那里采集DNA样本。这项工作后来被证明至关重要。然而，随着岁月的流逝，调查并没有什么进展。媒体对失踪女孩的报道很少。似乎没有多少人关心。这从未真正进入公众的视野。
There are varying reports depending on where and who you are getting them from about just how hard the police were actually looking. Most of the local media didn't even bat an eyelid at the story, even turning some of the victims' families away, refusing to give it any airtime. If there was any truth to that rumour about Albuquerque having its own Jack the Ripper, it looked like he was proven right. Society didn't seem to care. The story didn't really fade from the public's mind
关于警方到底有多努力地寻找，根据来源不同，有各种各样的报道。大多数当地媒体甚至对这个故事视而不见，甚至拒绝了一些受害者家属的请求，拒绝给予任何曝光时间。如果关于阿尔伯克基有自己的“开膛手杰克”的传言有任何真实性，那么他似乎是对的。社会似乎并不关心。这个故事并没有真正从公众的脑海中淡去，
because it was never really there in the first place. Nobody other than the families of the missing girls and Detective Lopez seemed to care. It was the 2nd of February 2009, five years after Detective Lopez had made up a list. And Christine Ross, who lived in one of the new housing subdivisions on the West Mesa, was taking her dog for a walk. Her dog started playing with a bone sticking out of the ground on an abandoned construction site that was supposed to have had new homes built on it by now. Christine felt uneasy about the bone.
因为它从一开始就从未真正存在过。除了失踪女孩的家属和洛佩兹警探外，似乎没有人关心。那是2009年2月2日，距离洛佩兹警探整理出名单已经五年了。住在西平顶山新住宅区之一的克里斯汀·罗斯正在遛狗。她的狗开始玩弄一个从废弃建筑工地上露出来的骨头，那里本应在此时已经建好了新房。克里斯汀对这块骨头感到不安。
It didn't look like any of the usual animal bones she had found in the area before. She took a picture of it and sent it to her sister, who was a registered nurse. Her sister got back to her almost immediately. It looked like a human female. Christine contacted the Albuquerque Police Department. They arrived and were able to quickly determine that it was most definitely a human bone. A crime scene was established. It would become the largest crime scene in Albuquerque history.
它看起来不像她以前在该地区发现的任何普通动物骨头。她拍了一张照片，发给了身为注册护士的姐姐。她姐姐几乎立刻就回复了她。这看起来像人类女性的骨头。克里斯汀联系了阿尔伯克基警察局。他们赶到现场，很快确定这绝对是人类骨头。犯罪现场被封锁。它将成为阿尔伯克基历史上最大的犯罪现场。
Human bones were found scattered in one section of a 92-acre piece of land owned by a home developer, KB Home. It was the work that KB Home had already completed on the site that made the huge task more complicated. The builders had done extensive grading and digging and a lot of heavy machinery had been used in order to get the land ready to build on. That work had totally changed the landscape and shattered many of the bones in the process, scattering their location.
在房屋开发商KB Home拥有的一块92英亩土地的某个区域，发现了散落的人类骨头。KB Home已经在现场完成的工作使这项艰巨的任务变得更加复杂。建筑商进行了大量的平整和挖掘工作，并使用了许多重型机械来准备土地以进行建设。这项工作彻底改变了地貌，并在过程中粉碎了许多骨头，使它们的位置变得分散。
The police had the call in state of the art equipment to help process the crime scene. Ground-penetrating radar, lasers, aerial photography and digital mapping were all used. In total, police dug through 40,000 cubic yards of dirt, digging down as far as 15 feet in some places. It took them two and a half months of processing the crime scene before they were satisfied that they had recovered all of the victims buried at the site. In total, there were 11 female victims. The youngest was 15, the oldest was 32.
警方不得不调用最先进的设备来帮助处理犯罪现场。探地雷达、激光、航空摄影和数字测绘都被使用了。总共，警方挖掘了40,000立方码的泥土，在某些地方挖掘深度达15英尺。他们花了两个半月的时间处理犯罪现场，才确信他们已经找回了埋在该地点的所有受害者。总共有11名女性受害者。最年轻的15岁，最年长的32岁。
One of the victims was also four months pregnant. Reconstructing the skeletons was a long and difficult process. It was like putting together a giant puzzle, and a lot of the puzzle pieces were broken. It would take one year before all of the victims were positively identified. The work of Detective Lopez in compiling the list of missing girls from Albuquerque and obtaining dental records and getting their DNA on file was a huge help to the investigation.
其中一名受害者还怀有四个月的身孕。重建骨架是一个漫长而困难的过程。这就像拼凑一个巨大的拼图，而且很多拼图碎片都碎了。直到一年后，所有受害者才被正式确认身份。洛佩兹警探在编制阿尔伯克基失踪女孩名单、获取牙科记录并将她们的DNA存档方面所做的工作，对调查提供了巨大的帮助。
In total, seven of the 11 victims found buried at the West Mesa already appeared on that missing list compiled by Detective Lopez. Some of the victims have more information released about them than others, but those seven were. Monika Candelaria, who was 21 years old. Monika enjoyed laughing, joking, looking after babies, and spending time with her family. She was a loving mother to her son.
总共，在西平顶山发现的11名受害者中，有7名已经出现在洛佩兹警探编制的失踪名单上。关于其中一些受害者的信息比其他人披露得更多，但那七个人是：莫妮卡·坎德拉里亚，21岁。莫妮卡喜欢欢笑、开玩笑、照顾婴儿，并与家人共度时光。她是一位爱她儿子的母亲。
She was last seen in South West Albuquerque on the 11th of May, 2003. Monika was reported missing soon after her disappearance. Her report was treated primarily as a missing persons case, but it was noted that foul play could be involved. Incredibly, detectives working the case heard a rumor that she had been killed and buried on the Mesa. That rumor would be proven right many years later, but nothing had became of it at the time.
她最后一次露面是在2003年5月11日的阿尔伯克基西南部。莫妮卡在失踪后不久就被报告失踪。她的报告主要被视为失踪人口案件，但有人指出可能涉及谋杀。令人难以置信的是，负责此案的警探听到传言说她被杀并埋在平顶山上。那个传言在多年后被证明是正确的，但在当时并没有什么结果。
The file was turned over to the cold case unit after a few months. That's where Detective Lopez discovered that the circumstances matched other missing girls in the area, and she added Monika to her list. Doreen Marquez, who was 27 years old. She loved jewellery and fashionable clothes. Always had her hair done and nails painted. She was a loving mother who was known to throw extravagant birthday parties for her children. In the year 2000, Doreen's life started to unravel.
几个月后，档案被移交给了冷案组。在那里，洛佩兹警探发现这些情况与其他在该地区失踪的女孩相符，于是她将莫妮卡加到了她的名单上。多琳·马尔克斯，27岁。她喜欢珠宝和时尚服装。总是把头发梳理得很好，指甲也涂得漂漂亮亮。她是一位慈爱的母亲，以给孩子们举办奢华的生日派对而闻名。2000年，多琳的生活开始瓦解。
She went through a difficult breakup and turned to heroin to numb the pain. By 2003, Doreen's behaviour had gotten very erratic. She would disappear for months at a time, leaving her children with their father or with family members. Her sister says she didn't live that lifestyle until the last few years of her life. That's when things started to unravel for Doreen and her addiction got the better of her. There are conflicting reports of when she was last seen. The police say it was October 2003, although a friend is adamant that she saw her after that.
她经历了一次痛苦的分手，并转向海洛因来麻痹痛苦。到2003年，多琳的行为变得非常反复无常。她会一次消失几个月，把孩子留给他们的父亲或家人照顾。她的姐姐说，直到她生命的最后几年，她才过上那种生活方式。那时多琳的生活开始瓦解，毒瘾战胜了她。关于她最后一次露面的时间，有相互矛盾的报道。警方说是2003年10月，尽管一位朋友坚称在那之后见过她。
Whichever it was, she was reported missing in 2004. Victoria Chavez, who was 26 years old. She was reported missing by her mother in March 2005. By that stage, she hadn't been seen or heard from in over a year. Veronica Romero was 27 years old. She had four children and was reported missing in February 2004, not long after she was last seen. Cinnamon Elks was 32 years old.
无论哪种说法，她都在2004年被报告失踪。维多利亚·查韦斯，26岁。她于2005年3月被母亲报告失踪。到那时，她已经一年多没有露面或消息了。维罗妮卡·罗梅罗，27岁。她有四个孩子，于2004年2月被报告失踪，距离她最后一次露面没过多久。肉桂·埃尔克斯，32岁。
She was friends with three of the other victims. Victoria Chavez, Julie Nieto, and Michelle Vauders, who you will hear about next. When Cinnamon's mother didn't hear from her for her birthday in August 2004, she knew something was wrong straight away. She reported her missing, although it took a few calls before that report was taken. She was told initially that Cinnamon was an adult and she had the right to cut contact with her. Julie Nieto was 23 years old.
她是其他三名受害者的朋友。维多利亚·查韦斯、朱莉·涅托和米歇尔·沃德斯，你接下来会听到关于她们的事。当肉桂的母亲在2004年8月她生日时没有收到她的消息时，她立刻就知道出事了。她报告了失踪，尽管在报告被受理之前打了好几个电话。她最初被告知肉桂是成年人，有权切断与她的联系。朱莉·涅托，23岁。
Enjoyed sewing, cooking and music. A beautiful and devoted daughter, a loving mother, and a beloved friend. Julie was a sweet girl who unfortunately fell to a drug addiction at age 19. Her mother tried to get her treatment, but it didn't work. Julie had a son who she doted over. She was a loving mother. Her family knew something was very wrong when she stopped sending birthday, Christmas and Easter presents to her young son. She was last seen in August 2004. Michelle Vauders was 22 years old.
喜欢缝纫、烹饪和音乐。一个美丽而忠诚的女儿，一位慈爱的母亲，和一位深爱的朋友。朱莉是一个甜美的女孩，不幸在19岁时染上了毒瘾。她的母亲试图让她接受治疗，但没有成功。朱莉有一个她非常疼爱的儿子。她是一位慈爱的母亲。当她停止给年幼的儿子寄生日、圣诞节和复活节礼物时，她的家人知道出大事了。她最后一次露面是在2004年8月。米歇尔·沃德斯，22岁。
She had one daughter who she was devoted to. A good, kind-hearted person who would give you the shirt off her back if you needed it. Fun loving always had a smile on her face and could brighten up the room with her personality. Unfortunately, she fell into drugs and started disappearing for days at a time. In weeks, then months. She would return to visit her father and he would give her small sums of money knowing it was likely going to be spent on drugs. But he gave it anyway in the hope she would keep coming back. One day she never returned.
她有一个她深爱的女儿。一个善良、心地纯洁的人，如果你需要，她会把自己的衬衫脱下来给你。热爱生活，脸上总是带着微笑，她的个性可以照亮整个房间。不幸的是，她染上了毒品，开始一次消失几天。几周，然后几个月。她会回来探望她的父亲，他会给她少量的钱，知道这很可能会花在毒品上。但他还是给了，希望她能继续回来。有一天，她再也没有回来。
She was reported missing in February 2005. Michelle was four months pregnant at the time of her death. The other four victims found buried on the West Mesa that were not on Detective Lopez's list were. Jamie Borralla who was 15 and Evelyn Salazar who was 27. They were cousins and were both last seen together at a family gathering in 2004. They left the family gathering and they were never seen again. Jamie was an outgoing 15-year-old school student who loved to sing and dance, read and play sport. Her smile was so bright it was enough to lift up anyone, no matter how down they were.
她于2005年2月被报告失踪。米歇尔在去世时怀有四个月的身孕。在西平顶山发现的另外四名不在洛佩兹警探名单上的受害者是：杰米·博拉拉，15岁，和伊芙琳·萨拉查，27岁。她们是表姐妹，最后一次一起露面是在2004年的家庭聚会上。她们离开了家庭聚会，就再也没有出现过。杰米是一个外向的15岁学生，喜欢唱歌、跳舞、阅读和运动。她的笑容非常灿烂，足以振奋任何人，无论他们多么沮丧。
Her older cousin Evelyn liked camping and outdoor activities and she was a good cook. Jamie and Evelyn were treated as runaways by police. Their family members saying little was done in the way of an investigation. In fact after the initial report their family says they hardly heard from the police again. Solania Edwards was 15 years old. She stands apart from the other victims as she was the only one with no known friends or family in Albuquerque. Solania never knew her father and last saw her mother when she was five. She ran away from foster care in Oklahoma in 2003 which is when she was reported missing.
她的大表姐伊芙琳喜欢露营和户外活动，她是个好厨师。杰米和伊芙琳被警方视为离家出走者。她们的家人说，调查几乎没有进展。事实上，在最初的报告之后，她们的家人说他们几乎再也没有收到警方的消息。索拉尼亚·爱德华兹，15岁。她与其他受害者不同，因为她是唯一一个在阿尔伯克基没有已知朋友或家人的受害者。索拉尼亚从未见过她的父亲，最后一次见到母亲是在她五岁时。她于2003年从俄克拉荷马州的寄养家庭逃走，当时她被报告失踪。
She was last seen in the Denver area in May 2004. Police believe Solania may have been travelling along the I-40 into State Highway which is how she ended up in Albuquerque. Virginia Cloven who was 23 years old. Virginia was a funny, humorous girl who took everything in her stride. The type of person that if she told you a lie two minutes later she would admit it until the truth because she felt bad. When Virginia was 17 and still in high school her brother was shot dead. Absolutely devastated and struggling to cope Virginia ran away from home. She lived with her grandfather in Albuquerque for a little while before moving out with a boyfriend. Tragically her boyfriend got hit by a car and went into a coma.
她最后一次露面是在2004年5月的丹佛地区。警方认为索拉尼亚可能沿着I-40州际公路旅行，这就是她最终到达阿尔伯克基的原因。弗吉尼亚·克洛文，23岁。弗吉尼亚是一个风趣、幽默的女孩，凡事都泰然处之。那种如果你对她撒谎，两分钟后她就会承认真相的人，因为她会感到内疚。当弗吉尼亚17岁还在上高中时，她的哥哥被枪杀了。弗吉尼亚悲痛欲绝，难以应对，于是离家出走。她在阿尔伯克基和祖父住了一段时间，然后和一个男朋友搬了出去。悲剧的是，她的男朋友被车撞了，陷入了昏迷。
Virginia lost the place they were living in and was soon homeless living on the streets of Albuquerque. Her parents last heard from her in June 2004. She called them to say she had a new boyfriend who had just gotten out of prison and she was going to marry him. Virginia was never heard from again. Her parents reported her missing in October 2004. 10 of the 11 victims were known sex workers. The one who wasn't was 15 year old Jamie Burralla. Jamie who disappeared with her cousin Evelyn Salazar.
弗吉尼亚失去了他们的住处，很快就无家可归，流落阿尔伯克基街头。她的父母最后一次收到她的消息是在2004年6月。她打电话告诉他们，她有一个刚出狱的新男朋友，她要嫁给他。弗吉尼亚再也没有消息了。她的父母于2004年10月报告她失踪。11名受害者中有10名是已知的性工作者。唯一不是的是15岁的杰米·博拉拉。杰米和她的表姐伊芙琳·萨拉查一起失踪。
Evelyn did have one prior for sex work so that common thread did still appear in their disappearance. A huge task force comprising of over 40 police was assembled to investigate the serial killings. It was called the 118th Street Task Force although Albuquerque police seemed reluctant in the early stages to refer to the case as a serial killing. Their common line being it is still too early to say what we are dealing with and that all possibilities were being considered. Some of the early considerations were gang activity. The idea being that they had been executed by gang members after running drugs. Another one was that a local pimp was responsible. Another being someone that had something against sex workers and who thought they were doing the Lord's work.
伊芙琳确实有一次性工作的前科，所以那个共同点确实出现在了她们的失踪中。一个由40多名警察组成的庞大专案组被组建起来调查这些连环谋杀案。它被称为“118街专案组”，尽管阿尔伯克基警方在早期阶段似乎不愿将此案称为连环谋杀案。他们的共同口径是，现在说我们正在处理什么还为时过早，所有可能性都在考虑之中。早期的一些考虑包括帮派活动。想法是她们在贩毒后被帮派成员处决。另一个是当地的皮条客负责。另一个是有人对性工作者有意见，认为自己在做上帝的工作。
Hard of putting together a list of possible suspects police looked for men with a history of violence against sex workers who lived in the area. Unfortunately that list wasn't short. The list of potential suspects was large. An interesting part of the investigation was a timeline police created using satellite photos. All of the victims found at the West Mesa disappeared between 2003 and 2005. So they were able to access satellite photos of the area taken in 2002. There was nothing unusual. The satellite photos of the area taken in 2004 were a totally different story.
在整理可能嫌疑人名单时，警方寻找在该地区居住的、有针对性工作者暴力史的男性。不幸的是，名单并不短。潜在嫌疑人的名单很大。调查的一个有趣部分是警方利用卫星照片创建的时间线。在西平顶山发现的所有受害者都在2003年至2005年间失踪。因此，他们能够获取2002年拍摄的该地区卫星照片。没有什么异常。2004年拍摄的该地区卫星照片则是完全不同的故事。
They showed tyre marks leading to bare spots which police determined to be graves. In 2005 the photos showed the tyre tracks again and even more bare spots. The satellite photos provided police with an evolving snapshot of the killer's work. It was in 2005 that the landscape of that area changed for good. That's when the housing boom was in full swing and large chunks of the area were subdivided and your estates were put up. Lots of digging and levelling of the land occurred. It was still on the outskirts of Albuquerque, still vast desert west of the homes. But all that activity is what police believe forced the killer to stop using that particular spot as a burial ground.
它们显示出通往裸露地点的轮胎痕迹，警方确定这些是坟墓。2005年，照片再次显示了轮胎痕迹，甚至有更多的裸露地点。卫星照片为警方提供了凶手工作不断演变的快照。正是2005年，该地区的景观发生了永久性的改变。那时住房热潮正如火如荼，该地区的大片土地被细分，新庄园被建立起来。发生了大量的挖掘和土地平整。它仍然在阿尔伯克基的郊区，仍然是房屋西侧广阔的沙漠。但所有这些活动是警方认为迫使凶手停止使用该特定地点作为埋尸地的原因。
There was just too good a chance he would be seen coming and going from the area, if not caught red handed. In 2008 the economy crashed. The home developer KB Home packed up and left the Mesa. But not before preparing the area where the victims were buried to have new homes built. This is where the landscape was changed by the heavy machinery, totally disrupting the crime scene. But on the flip side, if the crime scene was never disturbed like this, the victims may never have been found. Imagine if the economy never crashed, new homes would be on top of the burial ground. And we probably wouldn't even be aware of this case.
他被看到进出该地区的可能性太大了，如果不是当场被抓的话。2008年，经济崩溃。房屋开发商KB Home收拾行李离开了平顶山。但在离开之前，他们准备了埋葬受害者的区域以建造新房。这就是重型机械改变景观的地方，彻底破坏了犯罪现场。但从另一方面看，如果犯罪现场从未受到这样的干扰，受害者可能永远不会被发现。想象一下，如果经济从未崩溃，新房就会建在埋尸地之上。我们可能甚至不会意识到这个案件。
FBI profilers were called upon to assist. They believed the offender to be male, working alone, aged 35 to 50. He either lived alone or was away from home for extended periods. He probably had previous run-ins with the law for minor offences. And he liked to hire sex workers and was familiar with that world. That profile is pretty generic and could fit a large amount of people. And just like any other case where a profile is made, police can't rule out somebody just because they don't fit that profile. It's not an exact science.
FBI侧写师被召集来协助。他们认为罪犯是男性，单独行动，年龄在35到50岁之间。他要么独居，要么长时间不在家。他可能以前因轻微犯罪与法律有过冲突。他喜欢雇佣性工作者，并且熟悉那个世界。那个侧写非常笼统，可以适合很多人。就像任何其他制作侧写的案件一样，警方不能仅仅因为某人不符合该侧写就排除他。这不是一门精确的科学。
The FBI and the Aberkirche Police Department offered a $100,000 reward, which is still current, to anyone who assists in the arrest and conviction of the killer. This reward initially led the police to be flooded with crank calls, false confessions, and calls from people trying to be helpful, but who were misguided. Police have remained tight lipped about the cause of death. It's something that they have kept very close to their chest. All they will officially say is homicidal violence. This is an example of a piece of information they would deliberately hold back to help sift through the crank calls and false confessions,
FBI和阿尔伯克基警察局提供了10万美元的悬赏金，目前仍然有效，给任何协助逮捕和定罪凶手的人。这笔悬赏金最初导致警方被恶作剧电话、虚假供词以及试图提供帮助但被误导的人的电话所淹没。警方对死因一直守口如瓶。这是他们一直严守的秘密。他们唯一会正式说的是“他杀暴力”。这是他们故意隐瞒信息以帮助筛选恶作剧电话和虚假供词的一个例子，
easily able to dismiss them if their accounts don't match with the evidence they have. There are two main suspects who were most talked about with this case. The first is Lorenzo Montoya, a short, powerfully built man who was in his 30s at the time the West Mesa killings occurred. Montoya had multiple arrests for solicitation, including one involving violence in 1999. In that particular incident, the 23-year-old female victim was being watched by the vice unit. They observed her get into Montoya's vehicle, which they followed to an isolated spot. Montoya sexually assaulted her and started choking her. The victim believed she was going to die and suffered bruising around her throat.
如果他们的陈述与他们掌握的证据不符，很容易就能驳回他们。此案中讨论最多的主要嫌疑人有两个。第一个是洛伦佐·蒙托亚，一个身材矮小、强壮的男子，在西平顶山谋杀案发生时30多岁。蒙托亚有多次招嫖逮捕记录，包括1999年涉及暴力的一次。在那起特定事件中，23岁的女性受害者受到风化组的监视。他们观察到她上了蒙托亚的车，他们跟踪到一处偏僻的地方。蒙托亚对她进行了性侵犯并开始掐她的脖子。受害者以为自己要死了，喉咙周围有淤青。
She said it looked like Montoya was enjoying what he was doing. The vice police approached the car and arrested Montoya. However, the case never proceeded as the victim declined to testify. But it's what happened in December 2006 that lead many to believe Lorenzo Montoya is the West Mesa killer. About 2am on Sunday 17 December 2006, Montoya started a conversation in a chat room with a 19-year-old, Sharika Hill. After that conversation, they agreed to meet in person. Hill agreeing to go to Montoya's mobile home in the 4000 block of Blake Road, Albuquerque. She agreed to perform a dance for him.
她说看起来蒙托亚很享受他正在做的事情。风化组警察接近汽车并逮捕了蒙托亚。然而，案件从未推进，因为受害者拒绝作证。但2006年12月发生的事情让许多人相信洛伦佐·蒙托亚是西平顶山杀手。2006年12月17日星期日凌晨2点左右，蒙托亚在聊天室与19岁的莎莉卡·希尔开始了对话。对话后，他们同意亲自见面。希尔同意去蒙托亚位于阿尔伯克基布莱克路4000号街区的移动房屋。她同意为他跳舞。
On her way there, she picked up her 18-year-old boyfriend, Frederick Williams. They parked the short distance away from Montoya's home and Hill went inside. What occurred inside was a brutal, orchestrated and very violent attack. Hill was strangled to death and bound with duct tape by Montoya. After about an hour, Williams got concerned and went to check on Hill. And it's here that he got involved with a confrontation with Montoya, who was dragging Hill's body to his car. Montoya produced a gun, but Williams shot him first. Montoya didn't make it, dying at the scene.
在去那里的路上，她接上了她18岁的男朋友弗雷德里克·威廉姆斯。他们把车停在离蒙托亚家不远的地方，希尔进去了。里面发生的是一场残酷、精心策划且非常暴力的袭击。希尔被蒙托亚勒死并用胶带捆绑。大约一小时后，威廉姆斯感到担心，进去查看希尔的情况。就在这里，他与正在把希尔的尸体拖到车上的蒙托亚发生了冲突。蒙托亚掏出一把枪，但威廉姆斯先开了枪。蒙托亚没能活下来，当场死亡。
Police feel that the probability was higher that this wasn't the first time Montoya had committed a crime like this. It was too brutal and too planned to be his first one. As one officer said, This isn't the type of crime where you wake up one morning and just decide that you're going to brutally murder someone. They felt he had done it before. Unfortunately though, there is not a shred of physical evidence that links Montoya to any of the victims or to the crime scene. Detectives have stated they would have loved the chance to interrogate him about the Wes Mesa case. But now they will never have that chance.
警方认为，这很可能不是蒙托亚第一次犯下这样的罪行。它太残酷、太有计划，不可能是第一次。正如一位警官所说：“这不是那种你某天早上醒来就决定要残忍谋杀某人的犯罪。”他们觉得他以前做过。不幸的是，没有任何物理证据将蒙托亚与任何受害者或犯罪现场联系起来。警探们表示，他们很想有机会审问他关于西平顶山案件的情况。但现在他们永远不会有那个机会了。
He remains a person of interest. The other suspect talked about in this case is Joseph Blair. Seven days after the discovery of the first bone on the Wes Mesa, a female called police and said they should look into her ex-husband, Joseph Blair. Police knew him quite well already. Between 1990 and 2009, Blair had over 130 different contacts with police. Many of those run-ins with police were in areas frequented by the victims. On one such occasion, he was found with rope and electrical tape in his car. Before that in 1985, his DNA was found on the body of a dead girl found in the upper curkey.
他仍然是一个相关人员。此案中讨论的另一个嫌疑人是约瑟夫·布莱尔。在西平顶山发现第一块骨头七天后，一名女性打电话给警方，说他们应该调查她的前夫约瑟夫·布莱尔。警方已经很了解他了。在1990年至2009年间，布莱尔与警方有超过130次不同的接触。许多与警方的冲突发生在受害者经常出没的地区。有一次，在他的车里发现了绳子和电工胶带。在此之前的1985年，他的DNA在阿尔伯克基发现的一名死去的女孩身上被发现。
He was never charged with that crime. In fact, somebody else was sent to prison for her murder and was acquitted once that DNA result came back, matching Blair many years later. In the weeks after the victims were found on the Wes Mesa, Blair was actually under police surveillance and he appeared to be stalking sex workers on Central Avenue in Albuquerque. He didn't approach any, but he was closely watching them, continually circling the block and sitting in his car at a distance, just staring. One sex worker informed police Blair had tried to tie her up on one encounter she had with him, but she was able to get away. Blair is currently serving a 90-year prison sentence for four sexual assaults on minors, not related to the Wes Mesa case. He was only recently convicted of these crimes, which occurred in the late 80s and early 90s. The recent convictions coming about by way of DNA evidence.
他从未因那起罪行被起诉。事实上，另一个人因她的谋杀被送进监狱，并在多年后DNA结果回来与布莱尔匹配时被无罪释放。在受害者在西平顶山被发现后的几周里，布莱尔实际上处于警方的监视之下，他似乎在阿尔伯克基的中央大道上跟踪性工作者。他没有接近任何人，但他一直在密切注视着她们，不断绕着街区转，坐在车里保持距离，只是盯着看。一名性工作者告诉警方，布莱尔在一次与她的遭遇中试图绑住她，但她设法逃脱了。布莱尔目前因四起针对未成年人的性侵犯案件正在服90年监禁，与西平顶山案件无关。他最近才因这些发生在80年代末和90年代初的罪行被定罪。最近的定罪是通过DNA证据实现的。
He has openly talked about the Wes Mesa case before, claiming to have paid to be with several of the victims in the past. One of the few pieces of physical evidence located at the crime scene was a plant tag, located next to Virginia Clover's remains. The plant tag was traced to a nursery in California and that nursery sends plants to Albuquerque. Police conducted a search warrant on Blair's house on the 11th of June 2009. They seized business records showing Blair purchased plants from nurseries that sold the California plants that matched the plant tag found at the crime scene. Circumstantial at best, but still interesting. Blair's ex-wife said she found jewelry in their house that didn't belong to her or her daughter. Women's underwear not belonging to her was also found.
他以前曾公开谈论过西平顶山案件，声称过去曾付钱与几名受害者在一起。在犯罪现场发现的少数物理证据之一是一个植物标签，位于弗吉尼亚·克洛文的遗骸旁边。该植物标签被追溯到加利福尼亚的一家苗圃，该苗圃向阿尔伯克基发送植物。警方于2009年6月11日对布莱尔的房子执行了搜查令。他们查获了商业记录，显示布莱尔从销售与犯罪现场发现的植物标签相匹配的加州植物的苗圃购买了植物。充其量是间接证据，但仍然很有趣。布莱尔的前妻说，她在家里发现了不属于她或她女儿的珠宝。还发现了不属于她的女性内衣。
Some of the victims' families have reported that jewelry was missing from them. On the 12th of October 2009, police conducted another search warrant on Blair's house, where they seized some of that jewelry and women's underwear. As it's an active investigation, police won't comment if any of the jewelry or underwear matches the victims or if there is any DNA evidence on them. But considering the case remains unsolved, you would assume there are no matches. But we don't know for sure. There is nothing conclusive to tie Blair to the crime and he strongly denies any involvement. I mentioned before that the list compiled by Detective Lopez of missing women from the Albuquerque area at one point reached 24. There are currently six that are still missing.
一些受害者的家属报告说她们丢失了珠宝。2009年10月12日，警方对布莱尔的房子执行了另一次搜查令，查获了一些珠宝和女性内衣。由于这是一项正在进行的调查，警方不会评论任何珠宝或内衣是否与受害者匹配，或者上面是否有任何DNA证据。但考虑到案件仍然未破，你会假设没有匹配。但我们不能确定。没有任何结论性的证据将布莱尔与犯罪联系起来，他强烈否认任何参与。我之前提到，洛佩兹警探编制的阿尔伯克基失踪女性名单一度达到24人。目前仍有6人失踪。
Ana Vigil aged 20 years old. She was last seen in Albuquerque on the 21st of January 2005. She was reported missing a few days later and has not been seen or heard of again. Felipe Gonzalez aged 22, last seen on the 27th of April 2005 in Albuquerque. Nina Heron, 21 years old. She was last seen about 5pm on the 14th of May 2005 at her home residence in Albuquerque. She has not been seen or heard of again since that sighting at home. Chantel Weitz aged 29.
安娜·维吉尔，20岁。她最后一次露面是在2005年1月21日的阿尔伯克基。几天后她被报告失踪，此后再也没有露面或消息。费利佩·冈萨雷斯，22岁，最后一次露面是在2005年4月27日的阿尔伯克基。尼娜·赫伦，21岁。她最后一次露面是在2005年5月14日下午5点左右，在阿尔伯克基的家中。自那次在家中露面以来，她再也没有露面或消息。尚特尔·韦茨，29岁。
She was last seen in Albuquerque on the 15th of March 2006. Leah Peebles aged 23, last seen on the 22nd of May 2006. Leah had only been living in Albuquerque for two weeks. She was temporarily staying with friends at the time of her disappearance. She left the house on the 2nd of May after telling her friends she was going on a date with a man she had met at a local café, where she was actually due to start work the following week. Leah never returned and has not been seen or heard from again. Vanessa Reid aged 24, last seen on the 13th of June 2006,
她最后一次露面是在2006年3月15日的阿尔伯克基。莉亚·皮布尔斯，23岁，最后一次露面是在2006年5月22日。莉亚在阿尔伯克基只住了两周。她失踪时正暂时与朋友住在一起。她在5月2日离开家，告诉朋友她要去和一个在当地咖啡馆认识的男人约会，她实际上原定于下周在那里开始工作。莉亚再也没有回来，此后再也没有露面或消息。凡妮莎·里德，24岁，最后一次露面是在2006年6月13日，
walking away from the motel she lived at in Albuquerque after having a fight with her sister. All of these missing women match a similar background to the victims found at the West Mesa. The interesting thing about the timeline of these still active missing person cases is that Ana Vigil was the first to go missing of these group of six, last seen on the 21st of January 2005. This is after Michelle Valdez, who is the last of the West Mesa victims to have gone missing. Although Michelle wasn't reported missing until February 2005, she hadn't been seen for months before that. So if Michelle is the last of the West Mesa victims to go missing,
在与姐姐吵架后，从她居住的阿尔伯克基汽车旅馆走开。所有这些失踪女性都与在西平顶山发现的受害者有相似的背景。关于这些仍然活跃的失踪人口案件的时间线，有趣的是，安娜·维吉尔是这六人组中第一个失踪的，最后一次露面是在2005年1月21日。这在米歇尔·瓦尔德斯之后，她是西平顶山受害者中最后一个失踪的。虽然米歇尔直到2005年2月才被报告失踪，但在此之前几个月她就已经不见了。所以如果米歇尔是西平顶山受害者中最后一个失踪的，
and Ana went missing after that, followed by five other girls who match a similar profile and background, is it possible that one or more of them are also victims of the West Mesa serial killer? But for reasons already mentioned, the killer was forced to change his burial site. Another interesting note on the timeline that you may have already picked up. The last victim to go missing of these six still currently active missing person cases was Vanessa Reid, last seen in June 2006. Lorenzo Montoya was shot dead six months later. There is vast desert everywhere.
而安娜在那之后失踪，随后还有五名背景相似的女孩，她们中的一个或多个是否也可能是西平顶山连环杀手的受害者？但由于已经提到的原因，凶手被迫改变了他的埋尸地点。关于时间线的另一个有趣点，你可能已经注意到了。这六个仍然活跃的失踪人口案件中最后一个失踪的受害者是凡妮莎·里德，最后一次露面是在2006年6月。洛伦佐·蒙托亚六个月后被枪杀。到处都是广阔的沙漠。
Police concede it is very possible that there are other victims buried out there somewhere. Although they are satisfied that the 11 West Mesa victims were all buried within a contained area and no others were buried in that specific location. Has the killer been stopped by another method? Maybe he is dead or imprisoned for other crimes. Or is he still out there? Maybe he has moved to another place he uses as his hunting ground. It is possible that there are people out there who know something,
警方承认，很有可能还有其他受害者埋在某个地方。尽管他们确信11名西平顶山受害者都埋在一个封闭的区域内，并且没有其他人埋在那个特定地点。凶手是否被另一种方法阻止了？也许他死了，或者因其他罪行被监禁。或者他还在外面？也许他搬到了另一个他用作狩猎场的地方。有可能外面有人知道些什么，
who were maybe too afraid to come forward before. The rumours that Albuquerque had its own Jack the Ripper and missing girls had been killed and buried on the Mesa had to have come from somewhere. Detective Lopez was told this before the victims had been found. There are people that obviously know something. But a major problem with cold cases is that memories fade and witnesses disappear. Hopefully there is someone out there who knows something with the courage to come forward. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许以前太害怕而不敢站出来。关于阿尔伯克基有自己的“开膛手杰克”以及失踪女孩被杀并埋在平顶山上的谣言一定是从某个地方传出来的。在受害者被发现之前，洛佩兹警探就被告知了这一点。显然有人知道些什么。但冷案的一个主要问题是记忆会褪色，证人会消失。希望外面有人知道些什么，有勇气站出来。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。